on wednesday evening north korea
launched two ballistic missiles off its
east coast for the first time since
march this year
north korea state media released photos
and videos of the launch and it was
conducted from a railway in north
korea's central region
state media referred to them as
railway-born missiles
we see in the footage that a train
slowly comes out of the tunnel we see
some people in hazmat suits that come
out preparing for the launch the anchor
in the video says that the launch
occurred at dawn on september 15th
and this was the first time that north
korea was showing off its railway-borne
missile technology
the missiles flew about 500 miles at an
altitude of 37 miles before splashing
into the waters between korea and japan
which has caused alarm for officials
what's unique is that north korea has an
extensive railway network and this means
south korean and u.s officials now have
to track rail launch missiles as well as
road launchers and submarine launched
missiles
north korea has kept quiet for quite a
long time since the pandemic began north
korea has been consumed by domestic
problems it's kept its borders closed
largely due to covet fears and has
admitted to food shortages
a lot of north korea watchers say that
this recent missile launch indicates
that north korea wants to not only ramp
up pressure but also get the u.s to pay
attention to them and resume dialogue
weapons tests are definitely one of the
methods that north korea uses to dial up
pressure on washington
many experts that i've spoken to have
said
that because the us has been so consumed
with afghanistan and other international
matters this was sort of a chance for
north korea to grab their attention and
say you know we're still here we still
have our weapons and we still have this
military power to show off and they're
basically hoping to use that as leverage
once negotiations do eventually resume